>> EVERY SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPON
USED IN THE TERRORIST ATTACK ON
FRIDAY WILL LEAVE AND IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: NEW ZEALAND'S
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN COMES A WEEK
AFTER THAT DEADLY TERRORIST
ATTACK ON TWO MOSQUES.
DEMOCRATS MUTELY PRAISE THE
RESPONSE AND PUSHED FOR SIMILAR
ACTION HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
BERNIE SANDERS TWEETED "THIS IS
WHAT REAL ACTION TO STOP GUN
VIOLENCE LOOK LIKE."
WE MUST FOLLOW NEW ZEALAND'S
LEAD."
AND ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
ALSO CHIMED IN SAYING THAT
WITHIN DAYS NEW ZEALAND ACTED TO
GET WEAPONS OF WAR OFF THE
CONSUMER MARKET, THIS IS WHAT
LEADERSHIP LOOKS LIKE.
JOINING ME NOW, SOMEONE UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE,
HOUSE MINORITY WHIP STEVE
SCALISE.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU HEARD BERNIE
AND AOC PRAISING THE LEADERSHIP
OF NEW ZEALAND, SAYING THAT
LET'S GET IT DONE HERE.
ARE THEY RIGHT?
>> WELL, LAURA, THE FIRST THING
WE ALL SHOULD DO IS KEEP IN MIND
THAT THERE ARE 50 VICTIMS AND WE
SHOULD PRAY FOR THEM.
BUT WHEN YOU HEAR LIBERALS IN
WASHINGTON TALK ABOUT GUN
CONTROL, IT'S MUCH LESS ABOUT
GUNS AND MORE ABOUT CONTROL.
IF YOU LOOK, THEY'VE BEEN TRYING
TO CONTROL EVERY ASPECT OF
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, THEY
PASSED A BILL TO TAKE AWAY
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
EVERYBODY FROM THE ACLU TO
NATIONAL RIGHT TO LIFE SO THEY
WERE INFRINGING ON THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THEN A FEW WEEKS BEFORE THAT,
THEY PASSED A BILL TO TAKE AWAY
SOME MORE OF YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT ARE OUT COMMITTING THESE
CRIMES, ALREADY VIOLATING LAWS
ON THE BOOKS.
ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
DON'T INFRINGE UPON THE RIGHTS
OF LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S WHAT
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO IN
WASHINGTON.
WE HAVE A SECOND AMENDMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE VERY
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
WE'VE HAD OUR SHARE OF TERRIBLE
GUN VIOLENCE OBVIOUSLY THAT IS
REPREHENSIBLE AND HORRIFIC, SO
THEY POINT TO HIGH-CAPACITY
MAGAZINES.
GOT TO GET THOSE OFF THE
STREETS.
NO REASON TO HAVE AN AR-15.
ISN'T AN ERROR 151 OF THE MOST
POPULAR RIFLES IN THE
UNITED STATES?
THAT'S A LOT OF WEAPONS YOU HAVE
TO CONFISCATE I GUESS IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
>> LAURA, THIS IS THE DANGER OF
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THEIR
DEFINITION OF SEMIAUTOMATIC
WEAPONS, AUTOMATIC WEAPONS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN BANNED SINCE 1986.
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS, WHEN THEY
DESCRIBED THEM, IN MANY CASES
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT HUNTING
RIFLES.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT WEAPONS
PEOPLE BUY TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
IN THEIR HOME.
THESE AREN'T THE WEAPONS IN MANY
CASES THAT ARE BEING USED AS
SOME OF THESE VIOLENT CRIMES.
WE HAVE A SECOND AMENDMENT FOR A
REASON THAT SO PEOPLE CAN DEFEND
THEMSELVES AGAINST CRIMINALS.
>> Laura: YEAH.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED WITH AL EVAL SHE'D COME
OVER THERE AT MSNBC AND DANA
MILBANK'S.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I WANT TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE
BECAUSE NO ONE IN AMERICA HAS
SUGGESTED BANNING ANY GUNS BUT
WE HAVE SO MANY GUNS IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT IT CAUSES OTHER
PROBLEMS.
WHILE MASS SHOOTINGS GET OUR
ATTENTION BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
TRAGIC.
>> WE LIVE IN A DIFFERENT
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL OBSTACLES
BUT IT IS OUTRAGEOUS THAT ALL WE
HEAR, IT'S BECOME THIS CLICHE,
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS.
IT'S NOT DOING ANYTHING TO STOP
THIS FROM HAPPENING.
>> Laura: CONSTITUTIONAL
OBSTACLES?
THAT'S NOT HOW I VIEW THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> LISTEN TO WHAT THEY SAY.
THEY VIEW THE CONSTITUTION AS AN
OBSTACLE THEY CAN GO AROUND.
THE CONSTITUTION IS A FRAMEWORK
OF OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S WHAT MAKES US IN AMERICA
BETTER THAN EVERYBODY ELSE IN
THE WORLD IN TERMS OF A COUNTRY
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY HAVE RIGHTS
THAT ARE GIVEN TO YOU NOT FOR
MEN AND WOMEN BUT FROM GOD, AND
YOU HAVE THOSE RIGHTS FOR
REASONS OF THAT YOU CAN PROTECT
YOURSELF IN YOUR HOME.
>> Laura: I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ALL THE THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
THAT I CAN GET EVERY DAY.